here's a bit of zelenski's speech and he
was a comedian in Ukraine so I don't
know is this funny you tell me so so
here is the front line The Tyranny which
has no lack of Cruelty again the lives
of free people
and your support is crucial not just to
stand in such fight but to get to the
turning point to win on the battlefield
we have artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
it's not enough there's no amount that
would be enough there is literally no
number that would be enough and if your
implication is if we just give you more
artillery we give you more missiles we
give you more tanks you push Russia back
completely we get to exactly where we
were
what was it six months ago when this
thing started we already we still have a
problem already because of Crimea from
years ago but even if we do all of that
again
does that mean you have Victory if the
other guy has nukes
just
are any of these clowns thinking about
any of this stuff clearly but he
continued to get more laughs
we already built strong Ukraine with
strong people strong Army Strong
institutions together with you we
develop strong security guarantees for
our country and for entire Europe and
the world together with you and also
together with you will put in
Place everyone who will defy freedom put
in
[Applause]
this guy should be writing for Colbert
put in you got it I mean
who's in charge
does it sound like we are in charge or
the guy who showed up wearing a
sweatshirt does he not have a suit put
on a suit I get that it's all theater
but just put on a suit a sports jacket
with some khakis and some loafers that
would be just fine but no he's got to
wear his green sweatshirt all the time
and uh Putin put in genius she could
have made a poutine joke which would
have brought us back to Canada that's a
gravy that they put on their french
fries those weirdos